[Applaudissements]
il ya louisiane marie victoire hier
raphaël ya sacha comment ça va nickel
fer le programme ou pas ouais c'était
cool
moi je pense ça va cartonner mais moi je
suis sûr alors imhotep tout est vrai que
le business maladie non le businessman
avec le plus d'influencé sur internet
j'espère sur celui qui le plus d'enfants
sera en tout cas je vais pas mal merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis en dessous m'a dit oui c'est toi
qui a le plus d'influencé justement pour
alors c'est quoi la french house
thibodeau qui va définir alors qu'ils
marine on est un groupe d'amis avant
tout et laisser tout ça c'est ça alors
non mais maintenant vous êtes devenus
amis mais on a mis ses fois aussi nous
est en gros mais on a un groupe d'amis
et on crée du contenu ensemble voilà
c'est ça et ça a cartonné
aussi si ça cartonne et très vite tout
le monde vous voulez je sais qu'il ya
plein de chaînes qui voulait adapter et
vous avoir avec eux merci d'avoir choisi
ces 8es d'avoir choisi h2o productions
et webedia parce que c'est grâce à
webedia aussi qui font un travail
exceptionnel je les embrasse fort
d'ailleurs toutes les équipes de webedia
qui sont formidables voilà et c'est eux
qui savait que qu'on a travaillé
là-dessus et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un vrai métier un tic toc heures
et aujourd'hui donc on a décidé
d'adapter sa à la télévision juge
pourrait revenir sur un truc c'est que
c'est vrai que c'est vous qui avez fait
la soirée la met juste voilà on est
obligé raconte tous ses hôtes ont fait
la soirée en fait il aurait dans notre
dos voilà vous engueuler gentiment mon
sentiment c'est effectivement on a fait
une soirée maintenant c'est ce mois là
c'est des choses qui arrivent quand on
est jeune on a pris conscience que ce
qu'on avait fait je ne vais pas le faire
ça ça se reproduira plus et puis voilà
bon bah c'est pas beau à voir
c'est alors les acquis motel à 19 ans
marine takeda 23 23 dans quel âge de sa
chapelle 17 17
ralph alt a fait une petite animation
capillaire que j'aime bien j'aime bien
va-t'en 20 ans marie victoire 20 ans et
20 ans et louise l'inde 22 donc oui
c'est là ouais c'est genre la grande
soeur ouais hein c'est alors on va voir
des extraits parce que ça arrive sur ces
huit ça arrive lundi
sur ces 8 et imhotep chez vous qui avez
créé la french house est la recette du
succès c'est peut-être aussi votre
exigence imhotep il rigole pas à vue
tout alors franchement est-ce qu'il faut
arrêter ça dépend exigeant très exigeant
mais c'est pourtant qu'ils seraient les
cernes
bah je sais pas et vous d'ailleurs ben
mabrouk le blouson rouge je suis là si
tu t'appelles petite notoriété tu le
mets pas celui-là regardez on vous a
préparé une petite compil des coups de
gueule d'imhotep regarde nous sachions
cherche les crocs en fait au lieu de
regarder raf en train de passer je
comprends pas j'ai fait point express
achats en fait vous avez trois jours de
retard donc oui il faut se dépêcher
marie tétouan en fait quand je t'ai pas
où tu commence vraiment à me saouler en
fait c'est des chats errants marine donc
déjà moi je me refuse catégoriquement
une personne qui touche des chats
s'approche de moi c'est pas possible il
est bon ouais j'aime bien parce que je
vous dis je vous quitte parce que vous
êtes cette sympathique série joue un
coup de coeur pour vous et qu'on est
quand j'étais en mai quand on
aujourd'hui je suis vert parce que vous
faisiez quand quand on m'a dit on veut
peut-être travaillée que la french house
génie j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
s'il faut mettre la boîte en dépôt de
bilan de la médaille en est rien artiche
assez bien je les veux et on les a eus
et je peux vous dire que c'est énorme en
passe énormément
c'est vraiment l'événement parce que
c'est censé être un personnage de
l'ombre il se révèle vraiment dans ce
programme et puis faut surtout souligner
que ce qu'il a fait c'est énorme il a 19
ans seulement il a monté une entreprise
il fait des partenariats les grandes
marques donc bravo à lui c'est ça
m'arrangerait quel intérêt dans la villa
vous avez reçu la visite de pascal le
grand frère
il est venu juste après une votre soirée
clandestine qui avait fait beaucoup de
bruit dans la presse il a bien remis les
points sur les i et les barres sur les t
il connu l'émission pascal le grand
frère ou pas ouais j'avais pas compris
je pense que tu vas pleurer aujourd'hui
aussi ouais parce que je suis pas là
pour blaguer avec vous j'ai appris plein
de choses sur ce que vous faites tu vois
déjà les grands mais je sais pas pour
qui tu es pris la parole tout est prêt
pour une star c'est nous avait mis la
production à mal la chance peut-être
dans une villa qui coûterait une fortune
plus d'un million d'euros vous êtes vous
les mains et vous invitez 50 personnes
o2 tout le monde et vous êtes qui fait
clandestine magnifique qu'ovide
franchement vous méritez pas la place
vous avez aujourd'hui
franchement vous êtes irresponsables
tous et toutes
alors franchement sasha sa tâche s'est
acquitté faire le truc ou pas la soirée
ouais non mais moi j'ai des missions
j'ai adoré attaque bien fait c'est une
super expérience
j'espère que rhein deuxième saison rafik
toi tu t'éclates et j'ai fais toi t'as
kiffé ta tête en mai lui qui fait
toujours lui et sourire et qui tout en
lui même quand il est en énorme talent
assimiler tout temps qui alors il ya
marine qui était qu'à pleurer on a un
extrait où l'on voit complètement
bouleversé marine pascal le grand frère
a essayé de vous réconforter
je propose qu'on regarde l'excellent et
vous allez nous expliquer pourquoi vous
étiez dans cet état regarde maintenant
je suis sensible mais avec un
sympathique et au fond et je me dis
pourquoi toi ton est là aujourd'hui
pourquoi tu as vécu des choses pas bien
tu vois ça m'ennuie bon c'est vrai j'ai
pas envie de parler de ça mais je n'ai
pas bien géré la sphère déjà tout cache
pas derrière tes d'armes par le sourire
j'aime pas plus mais c'est pas grave
si tu dois placer c'est nécessaire ça
veut dire que tu vas encore si nous leur
qui sont là donc ses douleurs la fête la
sorte chez tremblay il a eu un bref je
semble adéquat et il m'a parlé de mon
passé et des trucs qui m'ont mis dans la
dépression et éradique donc on verra ça
on verra ça dans nos mairies à partir de
lundi qui va regarder moi j'adore voilà
éditions oui mais en fait moi je voulais
vous poser une question du mottay passe
comment les ados ils vous adorent ils
vous suivent évidemment mais c'est
marrant quand on est une des stars des
réseaux sociaux et de tik tok pourquoi
vous allez à la télévision alors que les
ados vous suivent le via les réseaux
sociaux
mathias le fantasme de la télé malgré
tout pour vous bah effectivement six
heures que la télé ça reste quand même
quelque chose d'assez spécial
aujourd'hui ils ont construit là la
plupart de leur carrière sur les réseaux
sociaux
la télé c'est un autre stade c'est super
sympathique et puis ça nous permet aussi
de s'ouvrir à un autre monde qu'on
connaît pas spécialement certains des
filles et puis on dit
bongo qu'est ce que vous diriez
téléspectateurs pour qu'ils vous
regardent à partir de lundi à limoges
mais écoutez il ya pas mal de choses
sympas qui se passe c'est compliqué de
de vent de la chose comme ça écoute et
enfin un groupe de personnes hyper cool
c'est que sur les réseaux sociaux on
perçoit pas tout ce qu'on fait on a
l'impression parfois que c'est juste un
groupe de jeunes qui s'amusent et qui
passe son temps à voyager s'est pas
réellement le cas et je pense qu'à
travers cette émission on va pouvoir
découvrir chacun d'entre eux est
découvert à quel point ils sont super
sympathique et à quel point aussi le
monde de l'enfance est un réel travail
parce qu'on les oublie aussi pas mal
on